posez lui vos questions on vous trouve
l'info il y a encore du flou concernant
les fameux frais qu'ovide scheller
optométristes vincent la rivière et sa
conjointe se sont fait demander plus
cher que d'habitude pour leur examen de
la vue en fait ce sont des frais pour
une photo du fond de l'oeil prises avec
un appareil spécialisé un examen que le
couple n'a jamais demandé
nous avons contacté la clinique pour en
savoir plus j'avais pour avoir des
informations sur vos examens de la vue
on nous a dit que cet examen est
facultatif mais quand on de pandémie il
est fortement recommandé
pourquoi parce que l'appareil utilisé
permet à l'aube de maîtrise de faire
l'examen tout en gardant ses distances
avec ses patients mais on demande plus
cher le reste de l'histoire est plus
embrouillée la clinique dit être limpide
avec ses clients à propos de ces frais
supplémentaires
mais monsieur la rivière lui n'a rien vu
soyons clairs rien n'empêche un
professionnel d'ajouter des flec pour
compenser ses coûts dus à la co vide
mais cela doit être bien compris par le
client avant que le service soit rendue
par la caisse et c'est pareil pour tous
les commerçants
alors si on a manqué de transparence et
que vous avez une surprise la caisse
vous pouvez refuser de payer les frais
supplémentaires si les trotteurs porté
plainte à l'office de la protection du
consommateur ou à l'ordre du
professionnel en question par simon
[Musique]